let's hear from some people in the
audience through Discord you can find
our Discord at davidpackman.com slash
Discord let's start today with Nevin in
Tennessee Nevin welcome to the show
what's on your mind today
uh hey David I just wanted to ask about
what your opinion is on the
Revolutionary left and a lot of people
revolutionary left I found have for some
reason support China and Russia and the
Ukrainian Invasion so I just want to
know your thoughts on that yeah you know
I think one of the things about the
Revolutionary left is there they claim
to be against imperialism and
colonialism when it's the United States
and do not apply the same standards to
other countries now of course
sometimes circumstances are different in
other countries than in the United
States if you take a country without a
colonial history that's tiny with a
small economy or whatever it would be
logical to think about the country
differently than the United States but
there are certain principles that to me
are of Paramount importance I'm against
authoritarianism I'm against
um uh theocracy I'm again you know all
these different things so when I see
authoritarianism in China or in
Venezuela or wherever
I'm against that because that's an
important principle to me and I would
like to see these so-called
revolutionary leftists maybe apply those
standards uniformly
okay thanks for answering my question
congrats on 1.5 million subscribers by
the way thank you and we are heading on
to 2 million that's the new that's the
new goal and I hope that we we get there
soon
yeah thank you all right good Nevin not
super excited about 2 million but that's
okay we're gonna we're gonna work
towards it it's gonna be a great thing
let's go next to win from Indiana win
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hey David how are you doing I'm doing
well
I still have a I have an exam in like
three hours in a regulatory economics
um so I have a question on monopolies
okay so what are your views on like
um not really regulating monopolies
because what I've learned and like from
Game Theory and such uh some monopolies
are actually good where it can compete
with bigger firms I'm kind of
paraphrasing but I'm not sure how to
articulate it well well so here's the
thing the problem with Monopoly power is
that it be becomes so you've got it
first you've got it back up and you have
to say what are our principles here if
you claim to be about allowing markets
to direct resources right like if you're
a supplant supply and demand guy for
lack of a better term you have to
recognize that a monopoly
is getting out of pure supply and demand
because the Monopoly can get a
Stranglehold on an industry to the point
where normal Market forces no longer
apply either because of barriers to
entry or the Dynamics of market share or
for other reasons so if you claim to
care about markets directing resources
and supply and demand
then it follows that you have to be
against most monopolies now there can be
Exceptions there could be areas of
society where for example I as a Social
Democrat think that in certain areas we
don't want markets to direct resources
so I've talked about Healthcare I've
talked about public education and some
others you might decide that there's
certain areas where Monopoly power is
actually okay or good either for
regulatory reasons or whatever but
the first question is what is your view
on markets directing resources that has
to be answered first before you can
answer the question about Monopoly power
so what I'm getting at is like social
efficiency
so for example in the event where
there's like uh let's say Walmart right
or whatever it's like a big big retail
company and there are like the let's say
there's Walmart and there's other three
small retail companies
um Walmart is like the dominant like
they have the majority market share yes
do you think it's okay if you allow the
two smaller Industries I mean two
smaller companies to merge in order to
compete with Walmart because you know
Walmart is dominating a market share now
if the government allows the two other
companies to come to emerge that would
be a competitive to Walmart which
reduces Walmart's market share therefore
it creates a better competition
still has the Lion's Share of the market
share even after the merger of the two
smaller players the Monopoly issue
really isn't with the merger of the two
smaller players it's with Walmart and
you've still got an old
primarily controlled by one player so
you're absolutely correct I don't think
it actually
is a tough one because the merger of the
two smaller companies doesn't change the
Dynamics of Walmart as the Monopoly or
the near Monopoly
but it could become a duopoly right yes
it could absolutely
and would you be in favor of that if
because you are you are a Social
Democrat and you believe in markets it
depends on the industry depends on the
specific it's such a specific question
you've really got to look at the
particulars of the situation very hard
to answer in the abstract
gotcha gotcha
yeah so like yeah I'm actually like
looking into it like according to like
looking at the market share and like the
math behind it like the whether if these
two companies merge is it really going
to create social efficiency which means
like is it going to give more options to
Consumers if you know I'm getting that
because that is a very important
question to be asking and also does it
benefit consumers many of these Telecom
mergers when you ask that question you
say well actually it's not really going
to be good for consumers in any way
it'll probably just lead to higher
prices and worse customer service
hmm yeah yeah give us a good luck on the
exam my friend oh thank you so much all
right there is win from Indiana very
very important question our sponsor
magic spoon is the breakfast cereal that
tastes amazing but without the sugar
carbs and the crazy ingredients magic
spoon has taken your favorite childhood
cereals and brilliantly transformed them
into something you can feel good about
eating because each serving has zero
grams of sugar under five net carbs and
is packed with 13 grams of protein so
it'll work for keto and low carb but
it's really perfect for anyone who wants
the occasional sweet crunchy treat
without the sugar their portfolio of
eight plus unique delicious flavors
allow you to never get bored my favorite
is maple waffle but they've got the
classics like cocoa fruity frosted also
cinnamon roll blueberry muffin our
entire team has been eating magic spoon
for years we love it but if you don't
they send you all your money back it's
really easy magic spoon has been
supporting the David packman show for a
long time they always give my audience
five dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below